How much money does being a smaller agency VTuber actually make you?
$12,084.03
Oh, you thought I was gonna ask the question and not actually answer it?
Nah, I don't gatekeep, so let's break it down.
I made $5,265.85 on stream elements.
That's tips during streaming.
$3,456.53 on Patreon.
From the alternative audios I offer on the site.
Then $3,361.35 from YouTube,
which includes memberships, super chats,
and money generated from ads watched by you, the viewer.
Side note, I stream every single day.
This does not include my 100% cut from Ubu Market Marriage.
This is just my first month,
so I cannot thank you enough for liking, commenting, and subscribing to support me.
And as always, hold back 30% of your income for the tax man.